the following is a presentation of the
st
louis chess club
the final round has been played but it's
not over yet at the 2021
u.s juniors and senior championships
here in saint louis
with a fourth draw annie wang sealed her
victory as the junior girls champion
and hans neiman was able to cap his
fantastic tournament with the u.s junior
title
but a draw was not enough for gregory
kaidonov to stave off a charging larry
christensen
the epic battle for the 2021 u.s senior
crown
coming up next
[Music]
[Applause]
[Music]
so
[Music]
hello everybody and welcome to playoff
monday
i'm your host sharon carpenser here with
grand master yasser sarawak good to see
you
sharon a pleasure as always has been so
much fun calling the action with you so
much fun now we crowned two
champions yesterday the senior
championship
still up for grabs it's going to be a
clash of the titans
isn't it absolutely yes it is hello
everyone and welcome to our live
coverage
of playoff monday gregory kaidonov
started the tournament with two wins a
draw and then hattrick
he led from start to finish but he
stumbled at the very end losing in the
penultimate round
drawing in the championship round
allowing
one larry christensen to tie with him
for first and today
these two gladiators will play for
the senior championship of the united
states
it's gonna be big now before we get into
playoff details let's head upstairs to
christian
for the drawing of colors
in the playing hall with chief arbiter
brian yang and the two competitors larry
krishnaser
and gregory kaidanov ready to do the
drawing of colors
chief arbiter please explain to us the
procedures all right good afternoon
so in each one of my hands has a pawn
one is white one and one is black
and so the player that will be choosing
which hand
will have is the one that had the
highest invitational rating
so that would be gregory could you
please pick one hand
all right you have white for the first
game and this is black so
and there you have it guys gregory is
going to start
with the white pieces in game number one
back to you in the studio
okay so gregory's got the white for uh
game number one
here's how the playoffs are going to go
down
all right there will be a two-game rapid
match
each game will be 10 minutes per player
with a two second delay
let me repeat that a two second delay
not an
increment if after the two games where
the players alternate colors
they the match is still undecided they
will go to a single armageddon game
exactly this is how armageddon works
five minutes for white
four minutes for black black wins with a
draw
now gregory starting with the whites
is he feeling good about that
a lot of people have very strong
different opinions a lot of people like
to start
with the black pieces imagining
themselves holding the draw
and winning with white now if you start
with the black pieces and you lose with
the black pieces
then it's easier to come back in a
must-win game
and win with the white pieces in
principle
i prefer black at the start he did
it's a little bit dodgy i understand the
other side of the coin as well sharon
let's talk about the games that got us
here in the first place it was a draw
for gregory on round nine
it was a must win for larry and he
pulled through
we were a little unsure there there was
a little back and forth is it going to
be a draw or a win
he ended up snagging the victory
uh here's gregory's how he got here
yeah the line score was like as i said
that
uh two victories at the start yeah a
draw in round three
exactly round four the beginning of a
hat trick right there
four five and six a slam dunk yeah but
look at the finish he only scores one
out of three
in game seven eight and a nine yeah
comparing
comparatively speaking larry was
was streaking i want to say
at the very end no defeats for larry so
a win on round number one followed by
two draws
two wins not a hat trick but a very nice
way
to start the rest day which was
immediately after round five
yeah followed by three draws and then
the big one yes he plays james tarzan
in a must-win situation and he pulls it
out exactly
50 years ago in 1971
larry christensen and james tarzan
you're not going to believe this
played it in a u.s junior championship
really
i did it 50 years ago
yeah that's pretty incredible and a
christian
welcome it's been so much fun calling
the action now we've got playoffs it's a
different animal
absolutely yeah i mean i'm very excited
i was upstairs i was feeling the nerves
of the players
larry was talkative he was chatting with
me a little bit talking about the
upcoming
tournaments here at the st louis chess
club he was just trying
to um well get rid of his nerves gregory
was much more secluded somewhere in
um the corner of the room waiting for
the games to begin so
let's see what's going to happen but the
nerves man
you can feel it you can't feel the
tension can you wow
and it looks like it's larry doing his
stretches his usual stretches that he's
doing something
you likes putting his hands behind his
back he was a polo
swimmer and he's always enjoyed
uh polo and water sports uh but
let's take a closer look at these two
players starting with larry
uh 65 years old from massachusetts with
a
uscf rating of 26.34
he's been a u.s champion three times
over the last time in 2002. 1980
8083 2002 as you said but also u.s
junior champion on a numerous occasions
and
how about gregory and gregory
his big competition today 61 years old
from kentucky
a rating of 2626 he played for us the us
team
in six world chess olympiads
and now this is a new one for him
seeking his first national
title uh for me that's an extraordinary
line at the very bottom i've known greg
uh well seriously for the last 30 years
maybe even a little bit longer but he
has always been a great
stalwart of not only the u.s olympic
teams but
also many many u.s championships the
very
idea that he has not won a national
title
especially because i really feel very
strongly that gregory
belongs in the world chess hall of fame
and he is in the world chance hall
yes so the idea that he's not been the
national
champion or even you know the
continental champion or some kind of
america's champion
he's won a lot of opens but never are
these
closed competitions pretty extraordinary
christian
absolutely and you know that he's
seeking that title the pressure is on
his shoulders in my opinion larry
is already used to winning this national
championships he has been
in this position before in his lifetime
larry
gregory he has not been yet so i think
that will
impact his nerves a little bit i'm still
having gregory
as the favorite in this one mostly
because of what larry mentioned
yesterday
he's so tough to beat in the opening and
with very short time control
those openings well the value of those
openings
is just quantifiable okay you're going
to larry yes
uh christian's going for gregory hmm
i'm going with gregory i'm gonna go with
i'm gonna go with gregory i think he
wants this really badly
and i mean he has been the lead from
beginning
to end i think he definitely has it in
him what's going to be interesting
though of course
this is rapid chess not classical chess
which is what they're used to i know
larry said this is something
a little different for him he's a little
uncomfortable with the rapid chairs i
wonder
how gregory will fare yeah this is
this is the point that classical chess
is its own discipline
rapid chest this 10 minute game very
very different
time management all kinds of things
about that
and larry actually likes classical and
bullet
bullet is one minute so he's like at the
extremes
he loves bullets now the thing for me
though
gregory does not practice blitz he
doesn't practice
rapids as far as i'm aware so he may
feel
like oh man this title this is
not my game jump in christian what's
your view on
gregory's rapid skills and by the way i
am not
very much aware of these players and how
they very usually ensure time controls
now that you're telling me that larry is
very good in bullet well i believe you
because you know these players
yeah what i do and know is that gregory
has a lot of students
so what he does he practices at least
his openings
very frequently i don't think larry does
that as often so
larry's main weapon at least at the
beginning is going to try to be
to escape the opening preparation of
gregory that's the way i see it if he
manages to do that
then he's probably going to be the
favorite
what kind of game is gregory looking for
versus what larry might be
trying to embrace when you say escape
the openings
because theoretical okay gregory is
looking for a theoretical battle right
now
and he played this move a knight to f3
and we have bishop to b4
and we're expecting the movement to d b
shop to d2 okay
indian with queen e7 has been a long
held variation by defense that larry has
played sharon
uh does rapid bring out a different set
of skills from a player
uh to my mind the answer is an absolute
unqualified big big yes
because in rapid it's almost this
combination
of playing very quickly
managing your time but also
being extraordinarily alert
to the tactics in the position because
you have to be able to calculate
very quickly and manage your time we've
seen
uh in the u.s junior championship
how very difficult it is to manage your
time properly
and i'm sure more mistakes happen
under this type of time constraint and
this is one question
right now nine minutes and 50 seconds
for
gregory and less than nine minutes for
larry
i think both players are very aware of
the clock
and both players want to want to stay
within the contact
zone of one another in other words they
don't want to fall
two or three minutes behind their
opponent and
by the way they're playing this bogo
indian
ethan begoliaboth was a player
from the 1930s and 40s and he liked
the defense that larry is playing hence
the name
the begoliabov indian nobody can say
begolia buff
so we say bogo
and gregory
okay that move is a real
versing a surprise move for me
because essentially gregory is attacking
the c7 pawn
and larry saying i'm going to move my c7
pawn
and attack your knight is your night
gonna eat
is the night is on a journey from
whence there is no escape
but gregory is playing just as you
described it
christian as you know can
larry withstand the opening prep
and this looks like some opening prep is
it valid
this knight to b5 is an opening wrinkle
that we have seen before
okay very top uh level games it did feel
like larry was ready
at least partially for it knight to b5
he played c6 immediately
knight c7 rook to a7 now queen to b3
this game
has b6 exactly hitting the d6 spawn and
now it's going to be that battle between
okay you're threatening that d6 pawn
right what i'm going to try to do is put
pressure on
your knight on c7 clear but the question
is
how are you going to do that now one way
to do that is to simply
wait for white to take on b6 because
once that happens you're going to have
moves such as
rook to a6 so let's see what he's going
to do in this position so let's say
i start with the move bishop c8 and
follow what you are saying
put pressure on the knight on c7 bishop
to c8 i think
d6 is the main move and might be the
only one right now so
d6 to cut the action of that bishop on
f4 the knights d6
exactly and if well as you say the
protection is is
cut exactly i have to take once you take
i'm going to go knight to d7
knight to david seven exactly i'm gonna
take the rook
you're going to take the rook and you're
going to take on
c7 and now i'm going to threaten the
move ruth way
trap the queen right clear so you have
to find an escape
right the only escape seems to be to
play the move d5
okay d5
and right now by the way larry is on a
minute and a half think
in a rapid game he is falling behind on
the clock he has
6 minutes and 30 seconds versus 9
minutes and 20 seconds that's a big time
difference
exactly and as i was saying at the very
start i think
sharon neither of these players want to
get significantly
behind on the clock b five
whoa yeah that move
looks a little bit wrong jump in
christian it's not the move
not the move that is not the move
i don't like the movie standing for
blunder right there potentially
yeah well that means that first of all
after the move b5 is played by larry
instantly gregory said well thank you
very much i can spot a free pond i can
take the pawn and the knight would
would be free if the pawn was recaptured
and in that case
then yeah larry's just going to be upon
oh larry had it had a nasty trick he
just played the move
a five a4 attacking the queen
that is perfectly normal and i will
actually have
a lot of options right now after a4 i
can go with the move queen to e3 and
after you take on b5
i'm not even forced to take back on b5
i can wait with that knight xb5 move and
start with the move d5
exactly attacking the queen and the
knight at the same time
that's the old days gregory if gregory
finds queen 33 the game is almost over
i think so too and he's reaching for his
queen
this looks like some absolutely superb
uh preparation opening prepper oh
that's really good as well it does
tickle the knight but
i love that move queen e3 with a hidden
x-ray
we thought that queen e3 this hidden
x-ray attack against the rook
was the way for gregory to go he went
queen c2 attacking the knight
on c2 at me attacking the knight on e4
at once also looks very strong let's be
honest the pawn up
uh this is exactly what gregory could
have dreamed of
yeah so right now he's in pole position
to take this one
he's also three minutes up on time he
cannot have
hoped for a better outcome out of the
opening and this is exactly what we were
expecting gregory is going to push the
pace in terms of
theoretical knowledge and larry was
aware of that
i think going into these very topical
lines maybe was
not the right approach the right
strategy for larry let's see how he
fares
now these two did face off uh on round
seven
and it ended up being a draw exactly
yeah larry was white
and gregory and larry really needed to
win at that exact moment in the
tournament
and gregory rebuffed him with
simply some superb uh
preparation as black larry got nothing
with the white pieces
it was a draw and at that point pretty
much i was
rather convinced that well gregory is
going to win
the tournament based on the outcome of
that game
let me just catch up a bit with the
player i'm going to just uh
hear take take take oops he didn't play
that that was the
after queen b3 pardon me just i'm just
catching up with the players
b5 takes a4 queen c2
takes knight takes and here i thought
gregory would just bring
slightest rook over to the open file he
actually played
knight e4 a common strategical
theme in this particular line of the
bogo
indian gregory is
hoovering the pieces off the board but
maybe he had a little bit more
advantage than what he's cashed in his
chips
a little early christian well still
plenty of advantage uh right
for uh white that is but i i do
understand what you're saying
especially right now wait a minute so
quinto b6 just came on the board
we're seeing la larry potentially taking
his uh pawn back
exactly too and if he would have meant
if he's
if he's successful on that and i don't
exactly see
i don't think you want to play knight c7
in this case
then larry will be very close to
restoring equality
so in other words uh from a very big
advantage
we think gregory has let it slip oh
significantly
he has indeed c3 on the board
what oh that's a tempo i beg your pardon
i was like
larry take the pawn but larry is
developing his knight
attacking the pawn on d4 and that pawn
on b2 for the moment
is not running away i like this move
knight c6
larry's back in business he's back in
town yeah look how quickly that can
happen
right the advantage shifted very
pardon the pun rapidly and that's what
rapid chess
does the advantage since can sometimes
almost feel like a hot potato as the
players go
back and forth and queen takes b2 to be
honest right now
i'm even considering black as probably
being the favorite just because
of the active pieces he has that queen
on b2 is very unpleasant for the moment
it could be a potential target for my
rooks nevertheless it's also
limiting the action and the mobility of
the knight on c3
of the rooks as well so i'm starting to
like black
well for the moment i still see that uh
ideas
i've got a very big idea on the board uh
christian
i want to play the move rook b1 when i
played the move rook b1 and i
the queen goes back to a3 i could try to
play queen d6 and i think larry is
reaching first queen
yes i was about to suggest for larry
that he bring his queen
all the way back to b8 off her trade of
queens and
oh d5 is hanging i beg your pardon i'm
getting this
all wrong queen b7 because there
is a hidden threat of knight takes d5
attacking the knight a discovered attack
with the rook
against the knight on c6 hence we saw
them with queen a6
uh still feeling that uh larry is for
choice or
it feels very even right now even for
and perhaps once we finish this game i
will point
to you a very nice tactic that larry
actually had he was winning
what he was winning in one move not
queen to b7 i will show it to you
after uh the the game because right now
the players are playing
extremely fast exactly knight to be
funny he had a golden opportunity
nevertheless i still
like what larry is doing and let's see
what does the time uh
looks like right now 355 seconds for
larry yeah and it's 50 50 for gregory
so gregory has a nice advantage on time
uh it was that move after queen b3 i
think it was the
one and a half two minute thing over the
move b5 which actually turned out to be
batman
and just a reminder there's a two second
delay it's no
increment in this game very very
different from
what the players are used to the players
are used to getting that
30 second bonus
for each and every move they made as we
saw in the championship
the classical chess here the two-second
delay means count it
one mississippi two mississippi and then
the clock begins to
count down after this queen trade we're
now in a double rook
night ending larry can take off
one pair of rooks and offer the other
pair
but notice that larry has
he actually has not made luft
on the king side which means potentially
the back rank is weak and it could cost
larry a tempo to release his king
while g3 is on the board think gregory's
still for choice
and we still we see that the rook swap
on the b1 and i'm thinking three minutes
now
for larry this knight on d6 has got to
go
this knight is really a thorn
and larry heard me rook to d8
get out of here he says that night is
bothering me
and had white the time
to play rook to b7 it would have
bothered him a whole lot
now knight to b7 whoa
knight to b7 by gregory putting himself
in a self pin
ah nah with the move rook c1 essentially
this is a draw offer
i see this as a draw offer as gregory
recognizes that his
advantage which he possessed earlier in
the game
is now completely gone and larry's going
to play a move like g5
and or h5 and he's done g5
i think that's the most accurate move
for the position and
our first game it was eventful uh sharon
it looks like it's heading for a draw
okay but
okay so if there's a draw then doesn't
that mean that
larry will come with the white pieces
for the second game and
he will have well let's see if he can
yeah he'll be all the same second game
could be the the big winner if not
armageddon
exactly yeah i'm sure it must work to
larry's benefit being that he's a great
blitz
player i mean if you're working with one
minute yes uh
and they just
now you have me on pins and needles
don't keep me
waiting christian you said larry missed
a golden opportunity
at that moment he played queen b7 what
was it
well in this position i was
feeling like white species are not yet
finding the right position
and indeed they are tangled up and after
knight to b4
threatening this move knight to d3
you're in big big trouble as white
you don't have a lot of ways out also
another very
strong potent idea is to put the put
upon on
a3 and then work around this connection
try to destabilize the connection
between the rook and the knight this is
key
if you move with the knight then you're
going to lose the pawn on a2 if you move
with a rook obviously
you're going to lose the knight on a3 so
for example if you play something along
the lines
the most obvious rook a to b1 now i'm
going to
keep my queen in your position
on d2 you cannot chase it around because
once you play rook to d1 well you're
losing the piece right so that's
a problem you have to get out of this
knight to d3
big threat so pretty much the only way
to do that
is to go e4 but after queen takes f4 g
takes f4
knight to d3 well right now i'm going to
pick up a pawn i'm going to have the
more active position
and this one is just simply looking very
very bad for white that is i can even
take on e4 first and then take on f4 so
for example if you do something like
this
i can take on e4 you take back i take on
f4
i have a pawn up the better structure
you have three weaknesses
that are going to play a very important
role in the end game
the position is just simply losing
technically losing for white so knight
to b4
that big move by black which
unfortunately for larry didn't see it
but
nevertheless uh he's probably not going
to go back to his engine to check what
he missed
he's just going to be relieved that he
survived this opening preparation
by gregory because that was beautiful
that queen
knight to b5 knight to c7 that intrusion
with the knight
in black's camp and then queen to b3 wow
gregory was in poor position to win this
one and he must be disappointed
with the final result so sharon that was
a kind of a game that exemplified
the advantages of both players that have
gregory's great opening preparation
larry's extraordinary
resilience yeah awesome exciting to see
how do you guys feel about commentating
on a rapid game is it more exciting to
you
than uh classical chess it's really so
fast-paced that we really can't we only
kind of like polish the surface
yeah you can't drill a little bit deeper
because the moves are coming so rapidly
so we kind of
like surf the surface
we've had three national championships
yes we have this is the final one and we
will be crowning
uh a senior champ uh today uh
but yesterday we had a ladies champion
yeah we did addie wang uh both of you
uh were behind annie all the way uh our
top spot
our champion at 2021
uh taking three thousand dollars and a
ten thousand dollar
scholarship as well from the dwayne
barber and u.s
chess yes she did but she was pushed
all the way by rue yang yan and the
other competitors in the tournament kept
it kept the pressure on annie she
responded and
in the juniors and hans niemann
i was back in my pick yes taking that 6
000
prize and the title of junior
champion and look at that tie for a
second
there were wolves nipping at his heels a
lot of them
nicholas checker came in second all of
the people who tied
first got 23 40 2 340
excuse me also of course hans gets a
seating in the 2022
u.s championships he's really excited
about that yes he was
yeah and is and as well as that ten
thousand dollar
scholarship from the dwayne fowler duane
barber foundation and u.s chess
dress and it was like especially for him
that uh david brosky and uh praveen
it was a draw for them and uh once han
saw that he was like i'm good to go you
just saw the smile
on his face still in the midst of his
game exactly yeah
and here's what the seniors are playing
for by the way
all right so yup gregory and larry
battling it out uh on a quick break
right now
uh before round two of the rapid game do
you believe it's a
more or less a 15-minute break between
the finish of game one and uh
start of game two so we got a little
things to talk about
yeah had gregory won clear first he
would have got twelve
thousand dollars and i think it was like
a nine thousand dollar price so i think
that they're
actually spit splitting the prize funds
first and second i think so
but it's all about the national title as
well
as we saw you know in those matchups of
the players
especially for gregory because he's
never had one i feel
that whoever wins today i know it sounds
cliche
but i feel that they're coming away
winners
if gregory wins you just kind of smile
and say
bravo gregory you know you got a title
you're the dessert
you know you win larry wins it's sort of
like bravo larry you came back
uh from despair in round seven when you
couldn't do anything against gregory
and you showed your resolve and the
champion
round exactly right now the senior
championship is not qualifier for
any other championship is it it
could very well be i'm not 100 sure
there is the
world senior championships and in fact
there's the world
senior team championships yeah america's
got the gold medal by the way
america so the seniors that yeah exactly
so the seniors that you've been watching
these last two weeks of the seniors who
have the gold medal but there's also
a senior individual
world championship and i don't know if
these
are qualifiers do the top two or three
go or are they all qualified by
based by rating so please forgive me on
that i'm not 100 sure
if this is a qualifier got it can we
talk about the difference between the
way these two came up
in the chess world so larry i heard got
into chess at age
12 as you did so it was a bit of a late
starter actually
i was much younger than i he actually
started
i he he talks about winning
the kindergarten championship of this
riverside school
he talks about it and then he says that
he won
the kindergarten championship but then
went into a slump
so that's probably what we're talking
about and then came and they came back
wow and then very rapidly progress
to the point where he skipped over
international master
straight to grand master uh and
meanwhile gregory
uh started when he was five years old
and worked solidly for a good two
decades
before he started seeing this incredible
success that he was right
and then again as we see gregory on our
cameras there gregory of course was born
and raised in the soviet union
and that's where he got his chest
grounding
his classical knowledge of the game and
when he first came to the americas
in 1990s as shabala
and other yere malinsky other seniors
were saying
gregory landed like a typhoon
on american shores because he
played in all of these american opens
world open
u.s open and he won them all okay so
he's won a lot of tournaments
but not the title ones did you ever get
a chance to play
with uh either of these two players
christian
yes i did yes gregory killed me once
not many years ago sorry sorry about
that sorry about that you should have
not reminded me about that game he uh
won a very nice game with black pieces
actually a couple of years ago so i
know uh first hand of his strength and
his theoretical knowledge
and everything that comes with that
soviet russian school you know
he uh calculated perfectly in that game
and he just bested me
but i was just looking while you guys
were talking yes at some of these lines
and
they're just simply mind-boggling i
don't know what gregory had in mind
maybe we will ask him
after the games but check this out after
queen to b3
d6 seems to be the main move and
probably the only move
in the position and now white has two
options
they can take on b6 and this leads to
this
wild variation queen take c7 d5 i'm
trying to get the queen back and now
you're going to try to stop me
from getting that queen back to e3 and
saving the position with an exchange up
i take on c6 you go rook to a8 and now
i take on c5 i take your knight then i
take your uh bishop then you take here
and we're going to have this crazy end
game crazy imbalance
rook and bishop and a pawn for the queen
so
this was one of gregory's options i'm
not sure if he would have went for this
because
instead of queen takes bc picking up the
pawn
he can also play the move c5 wow now
that's a very nice way to defend this
knight
on c7 indirectly defend the knight on c7
because if you take which is
the best move i am going to take on b6
that's going to create what we know
uh is a fork right on the queen and the
rook if you move the queen i'm going to
pick up the rook i'm going to be winning
a4 i'm going to attack your queen as
well i don't want to go queen to b4
because after queen to b4 knight to a6
it is black who is better in this
position as white will not be able
to defend this pawn on b6 if you go
queen to a5 well
i have this nice pin right now set up on
the queen and you cannot take on a7 so
finally
i saved my rook right so after the move
a4
best move is take take and i suspect
this is
what gregory was aiming for in this line
take on b3 we get this
end game supposedly white is a little
bit better nevertheless
given the fact that he does have the
double pawns on the b5
probably black will be within equality
margins
nevertheless wild variations that
gregory
showed his very well prepared for
and you can see larry right now lost in
his thoughts thinking
what just happened in game one what am i
supposed to do
in the opening against this guy and this
was this crazy nightmare knight to c7
and it appears sharon that this move is
actually
uh known the engine considers it
and for me that was a move that
really was very confounding because it
looks like the night's not coming out
and as it happened it didn't come out
but
gregory missed a big advantage and i uh
he's
most certainly knows that by the way
it's incredibly
warm outside yeah but in the playing
hall
there's good ac good ac i know i've got
the goosebumps going
on it feels very i know you guys are
feeling good right now it's just the
right temperature for you exactly
now here's where we stand in this
playoff once again
it's a two two games
of rapid chess the first game gregory
was white
the draw was made larry will
in the remaining rapid game have the
white pieces
and whoever wins that game that's it
there will be no armageddon yeah that's
the end of the tournament and there will
be the champion
and armageddon just again uh to explain
how that works five minutes for white
four minutes for black uh black wins
with a draw
if we get to that point if there isn't a
winner of this next rapid match
exactly and sharon when you get into
those
armageddon games if you do you think the
players play
rather quickly in the rapid power you
would you will see some
uh some some good hand-eye
coordination movement there you know
rapid twitch
isn't that with blitz doesn't it yes he
does he might be hoping for that
armageddon
yes all right well lots more chess
coming your way this summer it's been a
summer
chess here in saint louis as we get
ready
to uh welcome the players of the grand
chess tour
to st louis for the rapid and blitz that
will go from august
10th to the 16th yeah then the big one
the sinkfield cup
august 16th through the 27th then we
have just our
fun day this is where we do our trash
talking as team randy
goes up against team rex and the
ultimate moves the showdown
on september 7th yeah and then champion
showdown chess
9lx september 8th through the 10th
that's bobby fisher fisher random and
then the granddaddy of them all
in october we have the u.s and u.s
women's chess championship from the
fifth through
the 19th and believe me every all
chess player's eyes in america all
people who have chess
we'll be looking at those two events and
annie will be
there the following year and so well
hans now the crazy thing
is annie's gonna qualify herself already
to this year's u.s championship
but she gets the golden ticket
absolutely for 2022
as you said she is the now the reigning
uh girls champion and the players
they're
getting ready it is a kind of a surreal
thing
to watch these players playing over the
board with
masks on and that really must be
aggravating for the players and larry
spoke about that as well as being very
uncomfortable
uh for him but now he said he's getting
used to it yes
safety first though yeah i saw in the
drawing of lots
that the arbiter as well as christian
wore mass
because today in the state of missouri
increased restrictions for wearing the
masks
and nobody wants to take any chances in
the playing hall
hence even christian and christian you
were just wearing the mask for just a
short brief while but how did you like
it
indoors i don't like it i'm going to be
very honest with you i do not
like wearing the mask it's very
difficult for me to breathe but it's a
necessity
mandated by the state so we have to do
what we have to do
and social distancing as well it's not
that we don't like
each other yeah i miss you the reason we
are so far away from each other right
now
is for the same reason for safety
exactly by the way
knight f3 the opening moves there you
have this
wonderful bird's eye view of the game
and
again we have larry playing the
london system this is this early
development of his queen's bishop
to f4 london system
against igor novikov now i have to tell
you
that that did not bring larry any joy
in his game against igor novikov igor
just batted
his opening aside said this is not that
good for you
and no doubt about it whatsoever
ever gregory uh
witnessed and witnessed that game and
said i'm expecting that
he could play the london and uh anything
you can tell us about
this position christian this early queen
b6
makes sense are we threatening to take
the pawn on b2
well now with the knight on d2 it does
seem like we're probably going threat
and take that
pawn on b2 because the knight on c3
exactly
then it could bounce to b5 and then the
queen could get trapped
exactly so with the knight on d2 that
queen takes b2 is definitely a threat
right now and
we're going to have to wait and see how
larry chooses to defend against that he
has a couple of options
uh b3 is one of them nevertheless you
don't
always want to weaken dark squares on
the queen side
with b3 queen to c1 rook to b1 those are
all possible moves but i have to say d
takes c5 is also an option
and this is a very quick very sharp
variation yes queen takes b2
almost with zero hesitation once again
we see
gregory's preparation on display
uh the front burner now sorry sharon
please
i was just gonna say i wonder how many
of the uh the juniors and the girls are
watching this right now i know a couple
of them were in here yesterday saying
they're
looking forward to this and a a couple
of fun games
absolutely with a lot at stake yes
uh i want to say i have seen this way
way way way long long time ago when i
was still a junior player
and this move queen c3 was considered
a really good move for black
and the idea is that white
wants very desperately to play the move
c2 c4
but the queen's sitting right in front
of the pawn and it's very hard for white
in this case larry to attack black
center
and as long as that queen is sitting on
that c3 square
the move c2 c4 is
not playable uh christian in terms
is this position in your database i do
not have the game right
now but i do remember because i did
analyze this myself
with the white pieces and yes it is
still theory bishop to d3 instead of
bishop to b5
is also an option with other ideas such
as e4
at the right moment but bishop to b5
pinning that knight on c6
as you can see well that helps white
potentially
get a move such as bishop to e5 in or
knight to e5
those type of ideas and gregory chooses
to go with this move a g6 now
this uh delays let's say the castle for
a second but
it does seem like it's going to leave
the
open door for that bishop c8 to go
potentially to f5 and i think this is
the critical difference between g6 and
e6 in this position
very interesting and it does seem like
gregory has
knowledge to what he's doing right now
because as we can see
he has spent only 30 seconds on his
clock and his opponent
right now is thinking for the past
minute and a half and he played bishop
to eve bishop to e5
and that's what i was saying that i
think it's really
critical that white get in
the move c4 and or e4 in order to attack
uh black in the center and that was why
we saw the move bishop e5
forcing queen takes c5 by the way
gregory
uh chewing through white's pawn
structure that is
a pawn he just captured and he's a pawn
to the good
and now larry is thinking c4 e4
and or castles of those three options
do you have a oh a fourth option f6 wow
but look surprise guys i mean gregory is
getting what he wants
in these two games so for a theoretical
battle
yes a very imbalanced theoretical battle
in which
in this case he is a pawn up he wants to
see that
because we know how good how well
prepared he is
in the opening phase of the game so
right now we're seeing that
full display larry doesn't feel
comfortable in this position i can tell
you that
at least from a theoretical perspective
nevertheless
being upon down and having the dynamic
play this is usually the way
he plays as well as you were mentioning
yasser he likes
to swing a big axe yes he does and just
remember whoever wins this game if
somebody is to win this game they win
the entire tournament and they will be
crowned
chan exactly we will have the closing
ceremonies
here in saint louis and central west end
at the kingside diner at six o'clock so
uh unfortunately i would love to say if
you're in town join us but i do believe
these are
closed foundations because of
the uh covet now
if i'm in gregory's shoes and i've just
seen this move
c4 landing on the board i'm thinking to
myself
i want to get out of dodge meaning i
want to play bishop
out and castles as quickly as possible
on the other hand
i fully understand that castles and
knight b3
is going to come with a serious threat
of winning the pawn back
so gregory is probably contemplating
that he
is going to take this pawn but at the
same time
he's thinking to himself why on earth
did larry capture on f6 if not to play
a move like knight e4 so
he is in that state of trying to
outguess his opponent in a sense like
okay
in this position in this exact position
we can talk about this knight being in a
pin
meaning the knight is not moving because
the rook would be hanging in that case
so with the night not moving
it's rather surprising to see larry
voluntarily capturing that knight not
playing a move like c4 or castles
takes takes c4 on the board and now
gregory if you could tell me the clock
time sharon
it seems to me that gregory's taking
some time
yeah yeah well it's almost even to be
honest um
but gary upon me larry started slowly
yeah and seems to have caught up ooh
says
20 seconds no that is a
big time move bishop f5
trying to develop with a gain of a tempo
against the rook on b1 by attacking the
rook
now on the other hand that bishop move
i cannot imagine that gregory wants to
castle along
this could be you know deep deep
theoretical uh
preparation that i'm simply not familiar
with bishop
f5 i find this move to be
a bit extraordinary i would not have
guessed
this move myself does anyone have the
advantage
at the moment uh christian sorry
puzzling a need
move bishop to f5 because right now
we're seeing probably the rule come to
c5 now
the way i see this movie is that you're
trying to displace
that rook from the b file specifically
for the from the defense of
the bishop on b5 but also
from that attack on the pawn b7 so what
this move bishop to f5 does is
if you play the natural move rook to c1
well now you're not threatening to take
on d5 anymore because that bishop on b5
is under attack so that gives me one
move to develop my pieces either bishop
to e7 or either bishop to g7
and we see rook to c1 has been played
has it deep it has been played because
like you said leaving this bishop
unprotected uh there's something
compelling about rook b3 now
sharon you had asked a very very salient
question
because that's what chess players do all
the time yeah how do i stand
yeah said to me miguel neidorf what's
going on who has the advantage are you
favoring anyone at this point
uh i like being pawn up that
is my favorite living condition give me
that extra pawn
so naturally i'm going to say i would
prefer to be greg
gregory's position the extra pawn now
having said that there's no doubt
whatsoever
in my mind that larry does have
compensation
how good that compensation is well we're
still
have to find out yeah is it true that
gregory
is the most active grand master in the
country when it comes to teaching
by the way fun fact about gregory i
would say
yes and it's not just the fact that he's
active it's one thing to say i'm an
active player and i have a lot of
students
it's another thing to say i am the most
well received chess coach he gets
enormous accolades from his classes
and his students and he's considered not
only the most active chess coach
but frankly speaking one of the very
very best
in the united states in the world and
head of the us chess school
as well exactly and i think he works
very closely with greg
shahadi and the us chess goal by the way
captures on c4 now with the rook on c1
funnily enough
gregory forced the rook
to see one where he's got the threat of
a discover check picking up the queen
meaning that the queen's moving again
are we still in the throes of
theory we are not we
left a long time ago when that move
bishop to e5
came on the board so after uh bishop to
b5
we saw g6 and now castle was the main
move
no what happened was it was g6
correct bishop e5 that bishop d5 was a
novelty
that was the novelty uh prior to bishop
e5 it was
castle yes and then bishop to g7 bishop
to g7 and now i defend
my pawn with the move knight to b3
it has been discussed quite a few times
at the top level so actually i'm sure
gregory was very much uh well aware of
what he needs to do so
so larry was the one who instigated the
pawn sacrifice
with the move bishop e5 correct then
came queen take c5
and we could oops excuse me
we could have potentially guessed well
if larry had prepared bishop takes f6
he could have potentially guessed the
outcome here
right oops what do we have i've i've got
to refresh my board so we have
uh after bishop takes c4 yes g takes f6
c4
bishop went to f5 right correct rook to
ctc one take on c4
yeah bishop take c4 queen to e7 i see a
rook on c4 though well
wait for it error to c4 yes uh so sorry
bishop takes c4
queen c7 bishop to b5 bishop to d7
ah rook to c4 bishop to b5 now this move
bishop b5
has a nasty nasty threat not to win the
pawn with bishop takes c6
but to play rook takes c6 and
sacrificing the rook for an exchange
but at the end like for example at the
end of this
little we call it a petite combination
a petite combination white would end up
a piece to the good
so that was why we saw the move bishop
to d7
then wait for it you said rook came to
c4
holy smokes what's going on here and
then we saw aces
attacking the bishop on b5 rook to e4
and now
e6 i mean it's
queen to a5 pardon me queen to a4
uh reinforcing the pressure on the
diagonal
prohibiting the move a b5 because a
queen takes a8
uh need your response to this because
sharon's going to ask you the question
she's been asking me who stands better
yeah who has the advantage here
christian upon his pawn
upon his opponent as the asser always
preaches
so rook to c8 uh just feels like he's
holding black's position
if i manage to go bishop to g7 castle
then i'm just going to be
definitely much much better close to
winning now white is going to do
everything and queen to d7 is a perfect
move as well
uh the question i would have after
rooksy gate is bishop takes c6
the idea is is if you take with the rook
which i think you would prefer to do
i do have knight d4 and i'm winning an
exchange
uh christian that is correct so that was
maybe why he chose queen d7
exactly at that point uh once you play
bishop take c6 i would probably have
to take back with the pawn exactly and
allow you to take on a6 but he did not
want to give up
the pawn that he has and he played this
move queen to d7
and now we're seeing wow this is all
things are really
really heating up who has calculated
better
and this sharon is where why we
stopped when when you asked us who
stands better because
it is really uh
this move f5 really threw down the
gauntlet
for larry larry with the move knight d4
had wants the plane to move knight takes
c6
and the idea is if you take the rook
then the knight will come
back and i will win back oh this is a
sharp find by gregory yes f5 move and
now we see knight takes c6 and
everything is on pre right now but right
black is just simply winning after rook
to c8
no yes because you have two three pieces
under attack
which one are you going to try to save
knight takes c6
big money move to c8 right now don't
take the rook
don't take the knight don't take the
bishop but
move your rook instead see sharon how
tough chess is
yeah and then you die down to three
minutes i mean oh my gosh
rook to c8 leaving all three
white pieces he finds this move this is
going to be
a tactical brilliancy by gregory
rook on a8 to c8 i've got it on my board
and it's an extraordinary move because
if you look at the analysis position
white's rook is under fire white's
knight is under fire
white's bishop is under fire whenever
you're attacking your opponent's pieces
you're first he played it and he's
played rook c8 and i think
if i saw the camera well that jolted
larry backwards
he was not expecting that move he was
looking at all the capture
moves not this prophylactic move
rook to c8 and the idea is
that white can rescue one piece
but only one piece at a time three white
pieces it's over
guys this is over no there's absolutely
no way for
larry to get out of this rook to d4
feels like the natural choice
but then i will start taking your pieces
a takes b5
with an attack on the queen on a4 and
you're losing another piece at the end
of the whole story i'm just simply going
to be
a bishop up and that's huge that's not
going to allow larry to escape oh
any scenario i think larry
overlooked the impactfulness of this
move the two moves because rook c8 was
really a hidden resource but f5 really
threw down the gauntlet
my gosh you're saying there's no way no
way for larry
out of this morass he's in oh gee even
if he plays rook takes e6 it's not
there uh sharon please if gregory wins
as you're saying he's going to he is
going to be our 2021
a u.s senior champ and his first
national championship by the way as well
very very meaningful for for gregory now
the one thing you can't do at this
moment is write your victory speech
it's not over until the score sheets are
signed the offer
the arbiter's confirmed that yes indeed
you have one
now larry just played the move rook
takes e6
check christian does that help his
situation without getting another piece
from you pawn takes came
very quickly by the way and now two
white pieces
are as you say under attack
that's amazing we're going to see
something along the lines of bishop to
e2 i think this is the only way to even
try to keep some pieces on the board
once black manages to exchange the
queens it's all
over less than a minute left for larry
oh my goodness gregory has double
the time it's a it's a winning position
now for gregory
do not relax gregory getting a little
too comfortable there
exactly you know again don't write your
victory speech
until and 30 seconds left for larry
though
two minutes and 14 seconds
and usually in these situations when
given a choice between the bishop or
knight you take
the bishop so it can't drop back to c4
he's done that
now he's fighting five forces
that's the money move right there as you
were saying if you can get the queens
off the board and you're black
then you've got a winning ending and
this is a technical
win for black he knows it let's see his
conversion skills
exactly so now it's all about just
keeping the nerves
and you know it's a very very big
material advantage for
gregory we would be expecting him to
castle or bring his rook down he's
played rook to c2
a move i would approve rook to c2 knight
to d4
rook takes a2 i'm assuming
you
and it's a good pawn and gregory gregory
agrees
and after b4 knight to now
larry's just playing for for for tricks
he needs to play fast he's looking at a
possibility of knight c7
check gregory says hey look if you want
to
give up your knight for my bishop you're
welcome to do that
and larry's played king d3 after king d7
now he said i don't like that
decision bishop c5 and the knight
on b4 could very well
let's bring the other rook into the
attack i like it you like this there is
rook c3 check you're all right oh that's
a
beautiful oh rook takes me no
it's not yet the king almost mate but b3
b2
larry will resign oh this is it b3 b2
and larry uh ken this is game over that
pawn
wow what a day and what a
what a day for gregory right i i feel
like it's so well
deserved it's true he he this is it
this is guys he's going to resign he's
going to resign
congratulations and a win with the black
pieces gregory kaidanov our
first national championship and
on 2021 you are seniors champion
and look at that bag twelve thousand
dollars
in prize money that well for the with
the photo and the smile it looked like
he was
ready
very very humble uh gentleman
quietly confident and a very worthy
challenger in larry christensen of
course second place for larry
eight thousand dollars in prize money
absolutely i mean he came
back at the very end almost caught greg
he did catch gregory at the winning post
and somehow once again we saw
you know gregory's opening
skills really really magnified it was a
very nice game one that gregory
played uh he spoiled it at the end but
game two
no doubt about it he played some really
really wonderful moves
deserving winner how much prep do you
think he put into this into these rapid
games
i bet you put his heart and soul frankly
he'll probably come here you know like i
spent a few hours but yeah i really
think he put his heart and soul
and did he sleep do you think did he
yeah i think he got some hours
but uh we do have some announcements
that we have to make as we
hope that we'll get some interview with
the players uh yeah
tell us yes absolutely okay so uh
merchandise
yes time all right we've got some very
cool
swag to show you guys all right that
should be coming up
any second now okay there it is
the tie-dye t-shirt as a thank you for
watching the 2021 u.s junior
girls junior and senior championships q
boutique
is offering 20 of all regular price
merchandise
using the code champ 21 that's
a capital c-h-a-m-p-21
okay for today only i know we did it
yesterday we wanted to be kind and
generous again today to thank you for
watching
uh so another 20 off today
a very cool uh outfit right there uh
and christian you're with our champion
our big winner
thank you sharon yes indeed we are here
in the studio with grand master gregory
kaidanov
the national champion congratulations
gregory and welcome back to the studio
how do you feel right now this is your
first national championship how do you
feel
i feel good but what i'm going to say
probably will be surprising to you but
for me tournament ended yesterday i
already mentioned here that
competitive aspect today means much less
for me
than german from playing chess so
i kind of you know decided i died for
first place and
you know whatever happens tomorrow it
will not change
my mood and so and i would say the same
thing
as if i would lose so it was nice
to win but uh overall like i said you
know
it didn't matter my mood wouldn't change
if i would lose
this is still a national championship
what does
this mean put that into perspective in a
coronation mode for your career almost
um okay so
um i played in 18 u.s championships
and unfortunately i was very close
many times but never won a tournament
[Music]
so like i said you know it's nice to win
this title uh
but still uh you know it probably means
more for other people for my friends and
family than than
it is for me gregory you came to this
tournament
probably the best prepared i've ever
seen
in this event today's especially
in both the games you just completely
outclassed your opponent
in the opening phase how did you do that
i did a lot of work during pandemic i
worked on my openings as well as on
other parts of the game
and but also i have to say that there is
a certain
luck involved in this tournament as far
as openings are concerned because every
professional player knows
how you know you you prepare a lot of
your openings and an opponent plays
something which you
don't expect and almost every game i
played in this tournament
i was able to guess what my opponents
would play it was especially amazing
in the first game i mean in the game
against larry
during the regular tournament uh because
you know
he played maybe bishop opening
maybe a couple times in his life but
somehow i had a sense that he's going to
play
and everything which happened on the
board was pretty much
my preparation and today i was able to
use
preparations which i had for other
opponents at different times but yeah
it's just a little bit of luck that your
opponents played openings which you
prepared
gregory fantastic congratulations from
me guys
gregory how would you sum up your
experience during this
tournament um
there were two parts obviously the first
part when i was
super excited super happy when i had
five
five and a half out of six and then
there were
three last rounds when i already felt
a little bit fatigued and a little bit
of a pressure
because everyone was coming and saying
you know how well i played and everybody
expect me to win i i don't like those
situations and i usually
don't perform very well in those
situations and then i played larry
and i had black pieces and uh
and then i offered him i mean draw i'm
one point ahead of him i obviously
happy to draw but when i offered him a
draw
it was a mistake my position was a
little bit better and i
shouldn't have offered a draw and i felt
guilty about that
and this sense of guilt kind of carried
to the next game because when i played
white with alexa malinsky
i felt like draw probably would give me
a title
but because i felt guilty that i didn't
play against larry i felt i have to play
for a win and i maybe
pushed too hard and lost this game and
then i was down
obvious well you made it through
anyway are you going to celebrate
tonight your first
national championship title uh
no i i i guess i'm going to celebrate
with my wife when when i
get back home that will be the real suit
and with
my kids i'm sure they will be i mean via
video
because they all leave yeah they must be
so excited right now
yeah yeah so uh gregory first of all
congratulations thank you
very very heartfelt uh to you and your
family
a lot of people will enjoy your victory
as you say a little bit more
than yourself but crime and punishment
so you committed a crime
as dostoyevsky would say by offering a
draw in a superior position your
punishment was that round eight result
and then suddenly the door
was left open for larry to tie
i know this is really going to surprise
you
but the game one his b5 was bad and you
had a winning position
no no i knew that i knew that yeah i
mean i get
i knew it it just that you know i
i was i wouldn't say i was nervous i
actually i wasn't nervous but i wanted
it just to be over as quickly as
possible and so i played too quickly and
right after the game finished i felt
like yeah not
knight g5 move i played was bad i
probably should have played knight d2 i
guess and uh
queen e3 but no what i was going to
surprise you with
was that he missed a winning moment
in game one i couldn't believe it either
after queen b3 you mean no uh
it was the moment you're the the black
queen is on b2 he just played knight c6
he attacked your pawn on d4 you played
e3 right queen b2 rook
fc1 and then the game was drawn as i
would have expected but
well you know before all the critics
jump on you
and tell you what you missed and stuff
like that christian
showed to the people that there was
amazing move
knight b4 and larry would have turned
the tables
instead he played queen b7 christian and
uh that was well i'm stealing your
thunder in fact
well uh i don't think i will be able to
uh get that position back on the board
nevertheless you remember when he took
on b to that pawn
and i believe you played the move e3 no
no when he played two on b2 i played
c1 and now knight to b4 yes the pawn was
on e3 he strikes me to go knight to d3
right and the position the pieces are a
bit uh tangled up
for right so if i play rook a b one he
plays queen
three queen d2 oh i didn't see that much
exactly that's that's the that's a blind
spot move basically
right right yeah i mean
there will be mistakes yeah 10-minute
game
there is no question that you know lots
of mistakes are going to be
made and uh yeah i thought larry
should be a big favorite because you
know he's very good
speed player better than me definitely
and so you know like i said you know i
i was ready for any results but that
second game
gregory that move f5 just leaving all
the pieces on pre knight takes c6 and
now your opponent has three pieces on
piece
uh on pre yet you don't capture any of
them you play the move rook to c8
did you see that when you play the move
f5 um
and i think it was i i don't think you
know
uh i mean i knew i had two moves after
knight shake c6
uh uh rook c8 but i also could shake a
rook on
e4 and then knight d4 hxb5
queen shakes a8 and uh
you know i calculated that far and uh
so he's going to win his pawn back but i
have a bishop pair so even if ricky will
win
both b5 and e4 i should be fine with the
bishop pair so i saw this line and
this kind of gave me confidence that
that's okay and then
you know when the position occurred on
the board i started calculating group c8
wow and suddenly it works
it works but it just finishes the game
on the spot there's no way out for white
incredible yeah
once again gregory our hearty
congratulations it was very very very
nice on behalf of the
st louis chess club and scholastic
center
well done so well deserved congrats
congratulations
thank you very much a huge victory let's
take a look at the final standings so
you saw the champ
himself right there gregory kaidanoff
uh in first place he is the senior
champion 2021 12 000
larry christensen uh well i can't say
co-winner but he tied for first as
gregory said
eight thousand dollars richer yeah alex
yeah malinsky with 6 000
as well as uh fish fine alexander
fishbein had a nice tournament into that
tie for third
igor novikov at 4000 along with
james tarzan yep joel benjamin will be
taking
3 dollars and uh shabol off
two thousand five hundred uh as is
leonid and
mel except very very nice and a big
shout out
nice price fund for these senior players
it was a kind of reunion for all of them
they had
each other over the course of so many
decades
and it's sort of like a time to catch up
and say hey how you doing what have you
been doing
during the pandemic yeah you saw the
bonding before and after games as well
and through the magic of television
let's enjoy the uh
last 30 seconds of that game that
winning game this is the nice move that
inter mezzo move
rook c3 check the king king forwards
rook takes d2 with check the king
larry's king has forced up the board but
here's the problem there's a runaway
pass pawn on b4 and gregory says
with this pawn i'm going to promote my
pawn to a queen i'm going to play the
move b2
and that's going to be followed by rook
c1
larry recognizing there's nothing he can
do about that
offered his hand in not only resignation
but also with congratulations yeah and
you know
uh yeah something very important you
know what this means right
you guys were very lucky no no no i look
look i
chose the guy that got us to the ball
get take me to the ball a long time
that's all i've got to say
christian what do you think two of our
picks right
two out of three and yes how many of you
i got
one and a half now that i'm sticking all
right we'll give you that
we'll give you that but you were both
great competitors and i also want to say
sharon you got thrown into the deep end
of the swimming pool here on this one
you're bro you come from the world of
broadcasting and you said
i'll take up the challenge i did of
commentating and hosting
a chess show and it's sort of like whoa
that's going to be really really hard
but i have to congratulate
you i think you did extraordinarily well
thank you
on behalf of christian and i we're two
very
good grand masters we've worked a lot
with a lot of people and you did
wonderful so thank you very
very much it was so much fun it really
was
and you helped me through it and you
made me feel so welcome and comfortable
and you had me laughing like half of the
broadcast
now i have even more of a love of chess
exactly
all right well more chess before we say
goodbye
the summer of chess continues here in st
louis as the grandchester
the fourth and fifth legs of the grand
chess tour resume
uh st louis rapid blitz kicks it off
august 10th through 16th
followed by the big one the sinkfield
cup august 16th to the 27th
the trash talking one day event
of ultimate moves where it's team randy
versus
team rex come with every kibbits you can
all your wits about you for september
7th followed by
champion showdown chess 9lx september
8th through the 10th and that of course
that uh
showdown chess 9lx is 960
fisher random okay and then the us and
us women's chess championship
october 5th through the 19th the big
ones
right there lots of chess coming up
christian will you be
here for these championships we will
wait and see
only time will tell
yes you you know the line only time will
tell the answer we will see
very good one more look at our three
champions though
in all their glory let's take a look
there she is
international monster annie wang uh the
champ of the u.s girls junior
championship three thousand dollars to
her name now and that ten thousand
dollar scholarship
and the junior sheriff he's my guy hans
niemann yup the junior's champion
uh with the prize money of six thousand
dollars also with the same scholarship
from dwayne
uh barber and u.s chess and now our
legends champion yes and then our guy
gregory
so well deserved for all of them uh
twelve
thousand dollars for the u.s senior
champ
and that champion smile so once again
smile for champion you are absolutely
right
on behalf of uh the st louis chess club
and scholastic center
it was our pleasure thank you for
sharing both your
your week and i want to say and play off
monday so it was really really
a lot of fun it really was thank you
guys so much for joining us we loved it
hopefully you did too i'm sure you did
and
we'll see you next time around
bye guys
[Music]
this has been a presentation of the
saint louis chess club
any reproduction or distribution of this
content without the express written
consent of the st
louis chess club is prohibited
you